[Music]
mati surfing is basically riding waves
with your body okay and so hand planes
they are like a gas pedal so the more
you push down the faster you go and they
act helping your body and give you a
lift you know making these hand planes
out of you know surf trash basically is
our way of kind of giving back is
something that we love being in the
ocean is it's a way for us to connect to
nature so I mean the reality is is that
we're kind of constantly disconnected
from nature and anytime that we can do
something like going in the ocean you
know we feel that connection again and
then we get protective about it so I
mean I think it's great that the more
people that engage in going surfing
bodysurfing stand up paddle whatever it
is you know the more people that get
connected to the water and get connected
to the ocean they'll they'll feel better
at the end of the day and they'll also
want to protect
we spent so much time in the ocean that
I think we all have a vested interest in
in trying to keep it clean and you know
just be responsible stewards of the
materials that we use so I think it's
the next step see little bits of plastic
rolling around on the beaches it's a
very much disheartening to know that
that's worldwide and that it's only
going to get worse in a weird way you
know we we were sort of groomed from
little kids to just understand this
lifetime and this is all kind of common
sense to us we just understand that you
do things in a way that sort of
respectful of your resources you don't
waste things you try to use everything
you can and you know just growing up
with that lifestyle fit perfectly into
you know you know using old materials as
a new material so enjoy hand planes was
started by Kip and myself and I was
really getting into the sustainable side
of surfing and we started noticing an
issue of broken surfboards down at the
beach after a big swell and so we were
talking one day and we were we had
someone had come to my house and show me
what a hand plane was which I had never
even tried or even knew what it was and
we noticed that you know broken boards
still had plenty of good foam to make a
hand plane so I asked him if he could
make one and he went in in his garage
and a couple days later he came out with
one
and it starts out where edy will grab a
broken board or a blank he'll draw out
the different hand planes that we want
on that foam he'll cut those out he'll
sand them shape them pass them off to me
I kind of fine-tune them then I'll set
up my glassing stands and decide what
colors I'm going to go with for the day
and pick out a fabric and then I'll move
on to the next one I'll usually set up I
get five or six at a time and then glass
those and then move on to the next I'd
love to see what I can come up with
something that no one's ever done and
just get crazy and inlay different
different pieces of trash into glass and
just see how it's going to come out and
how it's going to look
how'd it go when you picked us up and
shot us all over the world and then we
just we made a kind of a career out of
it this company in general has really
started with environmentalism as the
number one priority and our mission
statement is to build the best product
cause no unnecessary harm and using
business to implement and create
solutions to the environmental crisis
and joy specifically they they really
capitalized on the whole recycle and
reuse saw materials it's great seeing
customers who drop off surfboards in
store then to be recycled into hand
planes that they can later use for you
know many years after their broken
surfboards are essentially trashed you
know ed Lewis is really good at reusing
that material and keeping it keeping it
in the water I think us as consumers you
know supporting those companies who are
recycling and reusing materials on their
product especially like enjoy Han Pines
is huge you know a lot of companies are
starting to use organic cotton and
recycled polyester on their clothing and
that's huge you know that reusable
material and the organic material is a
great step in that sustainability
it starts out with working with
styrofoam and that's the big thing that
surfboards have been made for him for
the last 50 years but a big problem with
styrofoam it's it's not good for the
environment at all learn more about all
these companies that are coming out with
things like sustainable type products
things like bamboo and there's all these
things called that green foams and
different technologies out there that
are really up-and-coming so they're
starting to figure out how to lower the
carbon footprint of what goes into
making a surfboard traditionally made
surfboards can produce more carbon
emissions than a flight from Los Angeles
to Hawaii another way to think about as
driving your car a hundred miles which
will emit as much carbon as it takes to
make a surfboard most wetsuits are made
of environmentally unfriendly material
called neoprene that consists
formaldehyde PVC lead and chlorine for
the production of neoprene in the surf
industry alone there's an estimated 250
tons of neoprene scrap waste each year
but now there's options for suits meta
bio rubber which is made out of
renewable plants with low agricultural
impacts
I see things and I pull things out of
the trash and I get inspired by just
other people's garbage like all drive by
row walk by a yard and I'll see a stack
of wood like old fence wood is just
rotting and I'd be like oh my god that's
ten hand planes right there that one
piece of wood or I'll see a broken
surfboard and a sticking out of a
dumpster and I've literally gotten off
the freeway taking another exit driven
back a couple of miles and pulled broken
boards out of dumpsters because I just
see the potential now of all this stuff
that people throw away not only that but
fabric as well old wetsuits I've picked
up old rash guards and and half tops of
old wetsuits and I'm like oh my goodness
there's like 20 straps for our handles
for the planes right there you know for
us we're looking in the future and we're
saying you know okay cool the past was
we developed products to be throwaway
okay that was the model okay we
inherited that but how do we how do we
design things differently for the future
so that we can develop everything that
we make to be reclaim Abul recyclable
biodegradable and it can go away so we
don't have this the answer to be
landfill anymore we have an answer to be
to become other things
[Music]
you